tout ce qui est noir des taches noires
c'est des métastases dans les ganglions
dans les eaux alors vous voyez ce
spécial là on a beaucoup mais il risque
de bénéficier de ce médicament là le
docteur Fred Saad s'enthousiasme au
sujet de nouvelles thérapies de pointe
approuvé par Santé Canada pour le
traitement des graves cancers de la
prostate on s'en va de l'espoir surtout
à des patients qui ont presque perdu
tout espoir de voir prolonger leur
survie et de maintenir leur qualité de
vie c'est ce qu'on appelle la thérapie
radioligans d'abord on scanne très
précisément le cancer du patient puis on
lui injecte des radios Ligue 1 un radio
Ligue 1 est composé d'une molécule
capable de reconnaître les cellules
cancéreuses du patient de se fixer sur
elle et de relâcher une particule
radioactive qui va ensuite les détruire
tout ça sans endommager les cellules en
santé c'est le genre de traitement qu'on
a rêvé de pouvoir
prendre un patient et viser
spécifiquement son cancer en moyenne la
thérapie permet de réduire de 50% la
progression des métastases et
d'augmenter de 40% des chances de survie
du patient et parfois les résultats sont
spectaculaires
Ivan un cancer de la prostate depuis 22
ans il a subi tous les traitements
possibles standards et expérimentaux
tout ce que j'ai eu a toujours
fonctionné seulement que c'était
temporaire en 2018 les métastases sont
partout dans son organisme en dernier
recours on lui offre une thérapie radio
Ligue 1
la magie opère rapidement dès le premier
traitement les métastases se résorbent
et 18 mois plus tard elles ont toutes
disparu l'effet était énorme là j'ai
compris que c'était vrai c'était sérieux
très très efficace mais je savais pas
combien de temps ça dure alors que pour
le majorité des patients de la rémission
est temporaire pour Yvan la Niel elle se
poursuit ma grande surprise mais je suis
dans les deux pour cent qui ont le mieux
réagi au traitement alors ça pourrait
ressembler à un miracle maintenant que
la thérapie est approuvée pour les
graves codes cancers de la prostate on
espère qu'elles permettra de traiter des
cancers moins avancés ce qu'on veut
c'est de voir si on l'aime plus tôt
est-ce que ça c'est encore plus efficace
mais de le contrepartie c'est qu'il faut
qu'on s'assure que c'est sécuritaire
rappelons que pour l'instant cette
thérapie n'est remboursée par aucun
système de santé au Canada ici normand
Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal